جنوب القطاع ونستطيع الاوضاع هناك معك
مؤمن
الشرافي نعم ازدهار الغارات الاسرائيليه
والقصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي لا يتوقف على
مدار الساعه تحديدا على مدينه خان يونس
والمناطق المتفرقه في هذه المدينه حيث
تتواجد اليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى انتشار قناصه جيش
الاحتلال على الابنيه المرتفعه في وسط
مدينه خان يونس والمطل على المنطقه
الغربيه من المدينه والتي تشهد هي الاخرى
اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهناك اشتباكات
تدور
بالاسلحه الرشاشه وايضا استهداف اليات
ودبابات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالصواريخ المضاده للدروع بحسب بيانات
اعلنت عنها كتائب الشهيد عز الدين القسام
وايضا سرايا القدس الى جانب ايضا باقي
الفصائل الفلسطينيه جيش الاحتلال وايضا
قناصه جيش الاحتلال يطلقون النار بكثافه
امام البوابه الشماليه لمجمع ناصر الطبي
وهي البوابه الرئيسيه التي يدخل من خلالها
المصابين والجرحى الذين يتم انتشالهم من
قبل المواطنين من مناطق متفرقه في المدينه
والوصول بهم الى مجمع ناصر الطبي بالاضافه
الى حصار تضربه اليات ودبابات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على عدد من المدارس
اليوم الثاني على التوالي وهي مدارس تابعه
للنور وتؤوي المئات من العائلات
الفلسطينيه والتي لا تستطيع الخروج من هذه
المدارس هربا من شده القصف المدفعي في
محيطها وايضا استهداف النازحين داخل هذه
المدارس برصاص قناصه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهناك بحسب افادات شهود عيان
عدد من الاصابات تحديدا داخل مدرسه حياه
وزهره بالاضافه الى جثامين وجود جثامين
عدد من الشهداء لا يستطيع المواطنون
انتشالهم او الوصول بالجرحى الى مجمع ناصر
الطبي نتيجه اطلاقات الناريه الكثيفه من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في شارع
البحر المطل على البوابه الشماليه للمجمع
في خانيونس منذ ساعات الفجر وحتى هذه
اللحظه ارتفع عدد الشهداء الى 14 شهيدا
بعد قصف اسرائيلي استهدف سياره مدنيه في
حي البراق غربي المدينه بالاضافه الى
استهداف قناص اسرائيلي امراه فلسطينيه في
منطقه المواصي بالرصاص الحي والمباشر ما
ادى الى ارتقائها شهيده هذه المنطقه التي
يدعي جيش الاحتلال انها امنه ويجبر السكان
تحت وطاه الغارات الجويه الكثيفه وايضا
القصف المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف ويستهدف
المنازل في منطقه وسط وغرب مدينه خانيونس
وتحديدا في محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي للدفع
بهم الى المنطقه التي يدعي انها امنه وهي
منطقه المواص يستهدفهم بالمدفعيه وايضا
برصاص قناصه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي